into trouble
progress bars animated bottom in
infinite progress bar is nice
hi everybody what's up welcome back to
css3 in 30 days today's day number 19
and you're gonna be coding in css3 only
some animated progress bars let me show
you what we're gonna be making here in
the final result you can see we got two
examples we got example one and two we
got this really interesting looking and
now a progress bar that slides up to
about sixty percent in fact it slides
exactly to sixty percent and it has this
like kind of like barbershop
you know stripy animated effect going on
and it's it's set within and it kind of
looks like an inset like parent
container with an inset shadow so it has
this really cool three-dimensional
effect some rounded corners it slides
all the way up to sixty percent goes
back resets and an example to the
interesting thing about this one is that
it goes to 100% but the thing is it has
a little tooltip that follows it to let
you know it's loading or whatever you
want to put in that so we're gonna be
making those it's it's relatively
straightforward we're gonna be messing
around with some animations again and
some keyframes so hang tight let's jump
in our code editor open up number
nineteen animated progress bars get
yourself set up and ready to go and
let's hang out for the next 20 minutes
or so and see what kind of trouble we
can't get ourselves into alright so here
is the index file I'm just going to show
you the markup real quick looks a little
bit like this so example one we got
animation bar one that's our class in
there we have a span with the style of
wit 60% simply just means the width of
that container is 60% we're gonna be
animating it to its its maximum width
and example number two we have a span
with a data label attribute that says
loading we could have made that say just
title or even alt but we're going to be
using data label
instead and we're gonna be using the
text in there just saying loading it
could be whatever you want it to be so
that's it for the markup jump into the
sandbox and get started let's start out
with the animation bar one we're gonna
say position relative display:block
there we go
padding five pixels font size sixteen
pixels again this is all just
housekeeping stuff line height sixteen
pixels border radius we're gonna make it
30 pixels so pretty rounded background
RGB a and it's going to be zero zero
zero zero point one so an almost
invisible black box shadow inset and
we're gonna say 0 1 pixel 2 pixels rgba
0 0 0 0.25 okay but we're also gonna add
another shadow to that if I left it like
so let's see what happens
so looks pretty good as is but if I were
to also add 0 1 pixel RGB a and then 255
255 255 and then 0.1 see what that does
that adds a it's hard to see but what
I'm doing here is I'm adding a little
bit of a highlight on the bottom maybe
if I make it more prominent you should
be able to see it so let me just make it
like one so it's a straight up white
line at the bottom you can see it just
gives it a little bit more depth so
let's make it actually I kind of like it
pretty bright let's do 0.8 on that one
okay that looks pretty good now what
we're gonna do is we're going to style
that span within it so we're gonna say
animation bar one span so we're gonna
style that out we're gonna say position
relative display so this is the progress
bar within the container that we're
styling up here in line block we're
gonna say vertical-align:middle want to
stay in the center there
height 20 pixels border radius 10 pixels
on the top zero and zero so that's zero
on the right zero on the left
zero and zero on the right there on the
bottom ten pixels on the left so ten
pixels of border radius on the top and
on the left and we're gonna say
overflow:hidden background color we're
gonna say f5 692 background size 100%
we're gonna be playing around with a
background image which is why we want to
use background size okay now we're gonna
create a gradient so let's just let me
just take that oh for a sec and just see
what we've come up with so it's just a
like a pink progress bar the border
radius is on the top and on the left
because if I take it out it looks like
this it's a square and I don't want it
on the right side so I'm gonna put that
back save it and I'm gonna keep the
right side square the left side around
it so it fits nicely within its parent
container and overflow:hidden because
we're gonna have a we're gonna have
something going on within the inside of
that so I'll show you in a moment
background size 100% because now what we
want to do is create a gradient
background image linear gradient
function and we're gonna say to bottom
just going to go from top to bottom
comma F 2 3 9 5 a comma and then the
next color will be B 9 0 C 2 B okay save
that check it out now it's got this nice
gradient
it looks very rounded that's a very
interesting looking progress bar a
static progress bar so far and now what
we want to do is we want to style we're
gonna we're going to animate it so we're
gonna leave a little bit of space for
that but right now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna style animation bar 1
span after pseudo-element we're gonna go
position:absolute top:0 left:0 right:0
bottom zero we're gonna say content
empty string so it appears background
size 100% and now we're gonna create
that that stripey barbershop pull effect
background-image:linear-gradient hang
tight 45 degrees so we want that on a 45
degree angle we want the next color
stopped to be full white let's go say
triple F 25% so at 25% color stop it's
gonna be white so if I save that you
probably shouldn't even really see
anything okay good and now what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna put a comma and
I'm going to go down to the next line
and line it up here and I'm gonna say
rgba 0 0 0 0 I want it to be totally
transparent so for the next 25% I want
it to be just invisible just like a
chunk of invisible black that you can't
see and then now the next line rgba the
same thing in fact we're gonna copy that
and we're going to paste it out and it's
gonna be at the 50% color stop okay so
now if I were to just close that out and
save it let's see if we see anything so
you can see the angle and things are
looking kind of odd here but trust me
this should work out well let's see
let's go back here put a comma and we're
gonna say triple F at the 50% mark
triple F at the 75% mark rgba we're
going to do that zero zero zero again
but at the 75% color stop and last we're
going to RGB a invisible close up the
parentheses of linear gradient semicolon
save it let's see what we've got
okay so we've got ourselves a two-line
so it kind of looks like a candy cane
actually it's around Christmas time so
this is kind of a nice little effect and
you can see that it's got so it's got
the angle red angle so you can see how
this works so from 25 to 50% you've got
the white and then from 25 sorry from 0
to 25 percent white and then you got 25
to 50 it's invisible so you can see you
can see that the red and so on and so
forth so that's what we created there
but now we need to change the size I
don't like the size of that remove that
comma so I'm gonna go all the way back
here I'm gonna overwrite background
setups that overwrite background size
and say 30 pixels and 30 pixels so that
so that should give us something like
this okay now we're onto something here
but I don't like how candy cane II it
looks despite enjoying the Christmas
season I'm gonna say 0.3 and just make
it a little bit more transparent there
we go so it's a little bit more subtle
of an effect so we're also going to
animate that so what we're gonna do now
is we're gonna go back up to the span
and let's animate that one so we're
gonna say we're gonna say animation
let's say progress a - bar one over the
course of ten seconds infinitely and
let's make its ease and then we have to
go down and make a keyframe keyframes
and we're gonna say progress - bar - one
and here's where we're going to start
creating that animation at 0% we're
gonna say the width is 20 percent so it
starts at 20 percent you get started at
zero if you want we're gonna say 50
percent in the timeline the width will
be 80 percent so it's it's gonna be
making it to 80 percent we might be able
to make this little bit more simple
let's say he's 100 percent zero to 100%
and this is going to go
up to 100% of the width let's just see
what that does
let's save that and let's just see so it
animates it's got an ease it goes it's
going to 100% see how it really slows
down at the ease there we don't want it
to do that we actually wanted to only go
to that 60% let's say that's the width
that it goes to and then it goes to
about 60 ease is too slow for me you can
make it linear if you want I'm gonna say
linear or ease in and it will be linear
essentially for the rest and over the
course of its make it six seconds a
little bit slow for me and it's gonna
ease in and it's gonna start speeding up
to the 60% mark and it stops like that
interesting I don't really like how that
looks
let's go with 0% it's gonna start at 0%
I'm gonna go to 60 and let's just make
it straight up linear let's see what
that does
so it makes it to 60% and then it starts
back so now if you want it to be if you
want it to go back I know it doesn't
really make sense so it's loading and
then it goes to 60% and then it would
just it just jumps back what you could
do if you really wanted is you could say
at the 50% of the time then it goes to
the 60% and then it goes back to with 0%
if you want it to be more smooth or just
an animation like this it's going boom
60% it's gonna make its way back it
doesn't really make sense for the
progress bar to do that because that's
kind of a tease you're like I'm loading
unloading unloading and then it's like
no I never mind so I'm actually just
gonna go back to our original style here
and at the 100% mark go to 60% and then
it restarts
and I actually kind of think ease might
be a good choice here so it's actually a
little bit more of a it slows its way
it's at the boom there we go
that makes sense that looks good to me
so let's keep going now what we want to
do is you want to animate those little
angled white candy cane bars I'm gonna
call them a barbershop pull candy cane
bars let's go to our or span after here
and we're gonna give it an animation as
well we're gonna call it progress - bar
- after - one clunky name but we're
gonna say 0.5 seconds infinite and it's
gonna be a linear animation that means
we need to create a keyframe so let's
say keyframes the name of it is progress
- bar - after - 1 and the animation will
look like so at 0% it's going to be the
background possession is going to be 0
and 100% and 100% of the time line the
background position is going to be 30
pixels and 100% let's see what that does
so see how it's now moving it looks
pretty cool so let's see what happens if
we change this value background position
to like 100 pixels let's just see it's
moving its position a lot further so
it's going really fast and it looks kind
of weird and if you did something like
10 pixels it's going to move to a lot
slow like a lot slower of a distance or
smaller of a distance rather so you can
see it's moving 10 pixels as you can see
and if I if I move it 20 pixels you're
gonna see again it's gonna look really
jumpy that's because it's not making the
full width of of that that bar we have a
set as a background size of 30 and 30 so
if we say 30 pixels
as the background position that's gonna
look like an infinite loop and that
looks nice
awesome okay so that's it for that
progress bar I'm liking that and now
let's move on to the progress bar number
two which is this one right here so and
we're gonna say animation bar
- so animation - bar - - we're gonna say
position relative display:block font
size 16 pixels line height 16 pixels
we're gonna go a background
RGBA that's going to be a zero zero zero
and zero point one box shadow it's gonna
be in set that's zero one pixel two
pixels and RGB a goes zero zero zero and
zero point two five okay see what that
looks like you can't see it that's
because there's no content within it
there's the the span within it you can
there's nothing in there so it's
collapsing and there's no hard-coded
height so that's why you cannot see it
so let's just for the purposes of this
testing it's got a height of 20 pixels
so we can see it there it is we're gonna
take that out in a moment
but I want that seam effect as the
example number one so that bottom
gradient so sorry box shot I'm gonna
copy this box shadow all together I want
the same box shadow style yes that's
what I was going for and we got that
white highlight at the bottom it looks
good
okay so we know that's there let's
remove the height hard-coded height we
don't need it I wanted to be a dynamic
height based on its child element so now
we're gonna say animation - bar - to
span and we're going to say position
relative display:inline-block
vertical-align:middle height 20 pixels
background color
let's do double O e6 e7 background size
100% because we're going to do a
gradient here using background image and
we're going to say linear Grady
it's gonna go to bottom that could be to
left to right to top however you want it
to be it's gonna be double zero be so
comma double zero B 3 B 4 comma and then
double zero eight zero eight one that's
the the two colors you need for the
gradient save that let's check it out
of course you're not gonna see it
because it has no width right now let's
give it a width just so we could see
there we go 20% width you're gonna see
the gradient top to bottom it's that
green to dark green looks pretty good I
like that style fills out the the parent
element it looks nice
I like it okay so I'm gonna remove that
width because I don't actually need it
now we're going to use the before and
after pseudo elements to create a
tooltip that you can see right over here
so let's jump down here we're gonna
style those up we just did tooltips
yesterday so this shouldn't be too crazy
for you animation bar to span before
pseudo elements we're gonna say
position:absolute right it's gonna be
zero positioned absolutely on the zero
bottom 100% display:inline-block width:0
height:0 now we're going to do basically
we're doing is we're creating the the
arrow ten pixels
solid transparent border right which is
zero border and left no border bottom
width is zero and then the border top
color so the one we want to appear will
be rgba 0 0 0 0.0001
and then content empty string
now that should give us a little arrow
as you could see just like that so it's
actually looks like it's pointing in the
top right but it's actually pointing
down because relative to what you'll see
here we want that little tiny almost
like a little speech bubble so that is
what we want I'm liking that so far and
now it's time to style up the animation
- bar - to span after pseudo elements so
this is the tooltip it's self
position:absolute right:0 bottom here's
here's fun here's the fun part calc
we're gonna do what we did last time
yesterday 100% so 100% down but plus
five pixels to give some space sorry
bottom is going to be 100% from the
bottom so it's going to move up 100%
plus five pixels for to account for that
arrow does that index just one just to
keep it above the parent
display:inline-block content we're gonna
use attribute and then select the data
label so that's another fun thing
whatever the attribute name is and
that's what you can use for for the
attribute there okay padding so it's
going to pull out the text of that
attribute this is what I'm trying to say
padding five pixels border radius is
going to be let's do five pixels you can
maybe do less if you want three pixels
font size 0.8 m so pretty small based on
its parent background color it's going
to be RGB a it's gonna be that zero zero
zero one again and the color of the text
will be triple F for white save that
check it out here in the browser there
it is that looks good loading it's
pulling that text it looks really good
now all we got to do is animate the
actual span so where's the span up here
animate bar - we're gonna say animation
and the name of it will be progress bar
- this is going to be over - six seconds
infinite and ease
from now we have to create a keyframe
and should be pretty simple it's gonna
be keyframes it's gonna be progress -
bar - - at the zero percent we're gonna
say width is 20 percent we're going to
start there and that 100 percent we're
gonna do with 100% very very simple save
that check it out in the browser so it
starts a start is zero it's not maybe so
you could see it and then it would
animate but check it out there we go
it's loading it's looking good it's
easing its easing its easing just to
100% boom done restarts animation that
is it for our animation of the progress
bar we kind of ripped through that one
so feel free to go back and check it out
again if you need to do that animation
progress animated progress bars are a
great thing to use if you're loading a
website or loading and loading screen or
anything like that building applications
I hope you enjoy today give you a few
ideas you'll see it tomorrow and be
number 20